[MUSIC PLAYING]
--"would make beings able to
comprehend the cosmic story,
and that we'd keep looking
into the dark energy of what we
don't know for something
we perceive that isn't."
Regents' Professor,
Alison Hawthorne Deming,
spent her childhood in
the idyllic countryside
of Connecticut exploring
the surrounding forest
and helping her father
tend the family garden.
They were writers,
they were performers.
They took me to concerts, they
got me dance lessons and piano
lessons, and--
so I grew up feeling like
the arts and nature, that's
just what life is--
those two things.
An excellent student,
she kept journals
and was a voracious reader.
Her parents encouraged
her to pursue her writing.
Was accepted to go
to Brown University.
I had done a program
for gifted students
at Trinity College studying
Latin between my junior year
and senior year of high school.
And then, I dropped out of
college because I was pregnant.
And I had a child.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
She moved out with her daughter
to Vermont, and for 10 years,
worked in the state's
first Planned Parenthood
clinic, all the while still
writing in her spare time.
And I decided that I
would make the commitment
to see what I could
do with my writing.
I left the public health work.
I got an MFA degree
from the Vermont College
of Fine Arts, which made me
do some extra work because I
didn't have the BA.
I got that degree, and
that really catalyzed me.
After that, things
began to open up for me
in ways that were very
rewarding, considering
the detour in my education.
Her most recent books are the
poetry collection Stairway
to Heaven and Death Valley--
Painted Light.
A Guggenheim Fellow,
she is the winner
of the Walt Whitman Award of
the Academy of American poets.
I'm trying to find a truth.
I'm trying to find a
deeper understanding.
deeper way to reflect
the complexity of emotion
that we feel about nature.
I think it's a tremendous
loss to the human spirit
not to be exercising
our strongest
obligation to the planet
that's given us a home,
and doing everything we
can to nurture it and have
it continue.
Deming came to
the U of A in 1990
as the director of
the Poetry Center,
then housed in a series of
rundown bungalows on Cherry
Avenue.
Of the many things
that Alison has been,
she's a supremely
skillful administrator,
and she's a fantastic professor.
She's been a steward
and a community member.
And across all of
those things, she
does it with a
generosity and a grace
that I find
enormously compelling
and something to aspire to.
Any young person,
or any aged person,
who wants to devote a life to
the arts and make a go of it,
[AUDIO OUT] respect, and--
you know, it's an honor
to try to mentor them.
Deming spends a part of each
year in the family fishing
shack on the Canadian
island of Grand Manan.
Nobody's very impressed that
I'm a writer or a professor.
I'm just, you know,
someone they've
known since I was a
little girl, and--
Along with her traveling,
teaching, and writing,
Deming is also a serious
student of jazz piano.
Here's something my
piano teacher told me--
Stravinsky said, if you give
me form, you give me freedom.
And that's kind of
what jazz is all about.
You've got the form,
and once you have that,
you can go anywhere with it.
You know where you're
going to come back to.
And I think that's a really
helpful paradigm in writing.
And, particularly, in the essay,
which can just ramble all over
and be very meditative
and go off, and you think,
what actually am
I writing about?
It's very much like a jazz riff.
And then you can come back
to the form, or the melody
or the--
[MUSIC PLAYING]